ladies and gentleman good evening it
gives me great pleasure to send this
message to you on the occasion of the
second annual global teacher prize
I'd be fortunate to have been taught by
some of the best teachers in the world
and I know it was an incredible teacher
can mean to a child a good teacher holds
the power to influence inspire and shape
a young person's life for the better
they represent the key to real change in
this world that is why I'm delighted to
be part of this event that honors
teachers everywhere teachers are also
uniquely placed to recognize and support
the most vulnerable and troubled
children in our society reaching young
people early on in their education and
providing them with the extra support
they need and give them the best
possible chance in life
this is an incredible responsibility and
this is why the Royal foundation of the
Duke and Duchess of Cambridge and Prince
Harry has partnered with the Varkey
foundation on a range of programs which
support teachers to help young people in
some of the most disadvantaged
communities of the United Kingdom I
would like to thank His Highness Sheikh
Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum for
supporting the teaching profession
through patronage of this prize and
sunny Varkey and his staff at the Varkey
foundation and finally I would like to
add my congratulations to the 10
finalists of the second annual global
teacher prize and to teachers everywhere
thank you for all your credible work